like i see you guys have been playing
pokemon a lot as well yeah i mean you've
been playing with a bunch of unfinished
yeah you finished it i didn't i think
he's finished like the main story
on stream we'll finish it yeah i didn't
get arceus that's all i have to do yeah
so there's like a lot of post post game
so i've heard like mixed things about
rcs which has stopped me from getting it
right now which is like i've heard like
it's a really fun game but it's just a
really empty world i mean
it's the best pokemon game we've had in
like five i don't [ __ ] know very long
a very long time i agree that's that's
like saying like this is the best big
mac i've ever had it's like
it's not that much it's way better than
the big bank down the road yeah this
isn't like saying that like ocarina of
time came before it in like the zelda
right yeah yeah yeah we haven't had a
fresh pokemon game in a long time i know
this is old news by the time this has
come out but i think it's still good to
recognize i mean i'm still playing it
i'm playing all the post game and i'm
doing all the side quests and everything
because i'm just that kind of gamer it
was hard it's a hard pokemon game it
gets very hard some of the battles are
hard as [ __ ] yeah it's kind of annoying
because it feels like
they revolutionized what they needed to
and somehow just completely like did
stupid choices for certain things right
they just like
make battles for like the first like
two-thirds of the game just like
way too easy way too easy right and then
randomly they're like how about we just
uh [ __ ] you and they just start making
them really [ __ ] hard it's not only
it but the thing that i noticed is that
it's not just the fact that there's just
this immediate jump in the levels of the
pokemon but like i feel out of all the
pokemon games the ai in this game is so
[ __ ] cute oh yeah it's it's smart
it's very very smart so it's like they
do some moves where i'm just like that's
like competitive level pokemon right and
i'm just getting [ __ ] because like i'm
so used to you know fighting like really
dumb npcs in pokemon games right like in
all the mainline pokemon games yeah and
this this time around it's like uh uh
we're playing 5d chess now yeah and i
just get [ __ ] yeah i felt like in
previous pokemon games just knowing the
typings of the pokemon was enough to
like easily comfortably get you yeah
yeah right whereas at the points in this
game i was like i know all the typings i
just can't beat this one guy this is one
fight in the game it's very difficult
right
and it took me like 10 attempts really
yeah
very frustrating so you can't just like
autopilot your way through the game and
you do have to after a certain point in
the game if you want to beat a cert
fight you do have to like yeah think and
grind and actually i doubt you'll do it
first time it's very difficult i managed
to do it first time but only because my
child was like uh there's a hardest [ __ ]
fight coming up
so you better uh you better at least
like prepare and i'm like guys come on
[ __ ] easy whatever did i do i almost
[ __ ] died i was like oh okay i should
probably uh i'd probably go grind a
little bit yeah but um yeah no but uh
like look i completely get why people
don't want to touch the game because
when i first booted up the game i was
like god this looks like a ps2 game like
doesn't it doesn't look great and it
doesn't run great graphically it doesn't
look great it runs like [ __ ] a lot of
the times especially if you're like
playing it through a capture card like
it's a little bit better i play it a
little bit on stream like on the switch
and it plays okay right it's still not
amazing like it's still nowhere near as
like you know [ __ ] mario odyssey
levels of like frame rate or anything
like that but i think you get over it
very quickly because the gameplay is
just so refreshing yeah and fun and like
yeah i get the world is like empty or
whatever but people said it was empty
but that's like i mean the pokemon
aren't the thing that you give it yeah
exactly you know i hated having to
collect these [ __ ] berries in the
trees all the time yeah i kept running
out of pokeballs
you know you could like go on a mount
but you can collect stuff on a mount so
you have to get off it to collect the
stuff and then immediately get back on
it really you can collect stuff on a
mount uh no you can't oh no no you can't
yeah no you can't you can
no you have to get off the mount
what oh oh like throwing it at a tree
yeah oh i thought you meant just like
stuff on the ground oh stuff on the
ground yeah yeah okay yeah sorry
i was like what yeah
but like the best part of the game is
just catching pokemon they actually like
recaptured that joy of being tan again
like the moment when you can just like
be hiding in a a little shrub and you
just [ __ ] yeet a pokeball just across
the field and you catch that pokemon
without noticing you is like the best
feeling
yeah and also like you can like let's
say you're level uh 30 you can catch a
level 70 pokemon with enough persistence
right if you just
just get very very lucky which is really
fun and it's like really like oh my god
this is so exciting it's a hype moment
when you like catch level 70 at level
30. but you can't control it but i mean
it's still like really cool so you can
have these really strong pokemon i felt
like they had a good range of pokemon
they didn't just choose the normal ones
you expect i don't know i think uh
people were a bit too harsh on it i
think i agree yeah i think a lot of
people love it yeah because i mean i get
you know i get the whole argument of
like oh it's nintendo it's game freak
you know they should have a billion
gajillion dollars to put into you know
making a smooth game and giving it the
best graphics but it's like
i don't know i i i personally think that
like the graphical
choice i guess that they went i mean i
don't really care about the story i
don't really care about graphics that
much me neither honestly
i don't either but they weren't
noticeably lacking i'd say yes
it wasn't that they weren't good it's
that they were like oh okay there were
definitely some moments where i'm like
oh that tree in the distance is freaking
out for no reason uh
let's just ignore that yeah but
there's good uh quality of life changes
i don't know it's pokemon right so when
they take they take one step forward and
then they just tear their leg off that's
what they do like they the moment they
have something good they start just
[ __ ] it up and i bet
i hope that we get more games like this
because they basically made it so that
you don't need to battle but also the
battling is way smoother there's not
this animation [ __ ]
happens you know you can run around you
can it's good but i know it's pokemon so
they're going to be like all right now
let's just get rid of that let's not do
that anymore and it's like why what's
wrong with you yeah i really hope that
enough enough fans need to make a
[ __ ] opera for them to like bring
back a second i don't know i feel like
pokemon fans are loud as [ __ ] i feel
like it's just pokemon companies doing
their own thing yeah that's usually like
it's just the pokemon company being like
we can make whatever the [ __ ] we want we
know you'll buy it yeah i mean they will
i mean pokemon's like the most
profitable yeah like franchise of all
time for like a reason right it's a fun
game though i'd say uh i think i said it
was six or seven six or seven yeah i'd
give it like yeah seven or eight i'd say
well it's a really refreshing
considering i bought the uh pearl and
diamond remake and i have barely had the
motivation to even put it in my switch
yeah